what is going on everybody welcome to
part 5 of our data analysis with Python
and pandas tutorial series in this video
what we're we talking about is combining
data frames and we're going to cover the
first two major ways and then the next
tutorial will cover two more the first
two that we're going to cover here is
concatenating and appending data frames
so with let's just go ahead and hop into
it so first of all we're going to of
course need to import pandas as PD but
I'm also going to save us like five
minutes probably of writing and there
will be a link in the description for
you guys to go to the text based routing
with this tutorial go there and if you
want of course you can always follow
along the text versions and skip the
video or vice versa or whatever but at
least for now what I'm going to do is
just have us copy and paste from there
these three data frames that I'll just
save as time from writing and there's
really no nothing to be gained by us
writing all this out so anyway I will
just point out though that there are two
major you know differences between all
of these data frames so data frame 1 in
3 they have the same index but they have
different columns ok so one in three
they don't share this third column ok D
F 2 and 3 have different indexes but
they share the same well actually they
also have different columns so they have
different indexes and different columns
now we can can with concatenation we can
talk about really there's a really
multiple things that we do with
concatenation but first we'll just do a
really simple concatenation
so we'll say concat equals PT concat and
we'll concatenate even concatenate a
list in theory we could do DF 1 2 & 3
but let's just do DF 1 and DF 2 first
and then we'll print out and cat let's
just print out that result so what we
get is this result here so that was def
1 plus DF - well DF 1 & 2 had the
identical columns right so that was just
a continuation of the index
so they've become a single data frame
but in our case what we're interested
maybe in doing is adding columns right
instead of instead of rows and with like
our real estate example that's exactly
what we want to do we'll have a similar
index the date index but instead what
we're going to have is by date it will
be the index but then each column will
be the housing price index for each
state right because that's our goal so
that's what we're going to cover here
and the way that we're going to do that
let's close this out like what if now
instead of can cat DF 1 DF 2 what if we
add DF 3 and prints you can now what
we're left with here is some not in
numbers because the data didn't exist
for that that index in theory but if you
look we have two mm one two and three
four what would have been nice is if
these values here were populated right
here right in his Nan's because they
could be and you'll see too that they
could easily go there because also the
other values 80 85 88 and 85 80 85 88 85
right all the other values could have
gone in there just fine but with
concatenation that's not really going to
work so those are that's the basic of
you know coverage of concatenation what
it's doing is it's going to add to the
bottom and it's not necessarily going to
do it very intuitively so we'll close
out of this the next thing we're going
to cover is appending so what if I'm
just going to delete these but you can
leave them there for your notes or
whatever what if we said DF 4 equals DF
1 dot and we'll do dot append DF 2 so
what we do with appending is it's just
like appending a file or whatever it
just adds to the end okay so what that's
going to do for us is add to the very
end and because the indexes aren't
identical right this adds to this index
that should work as we might expect so
now we'll print EF for run that and
there you go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and all the
information is there no not
numbers no repeating of datas data
columns and so on so one thing to note
with append though is is really append
data frames aren't meant to be updated
they're meant to be manipulated and
maybe make new columns based on existing
data but they're not really meant to
have new data input into them so it's a
panda's data frame is not a database or
a table in the database okay so if
that's what you want to do you need a
table in a database pandas is meant just
purely for data manipulation and
analysis although you can append to it
it's just not going to be very efficient
so anyways there is that now what
happens if instead of D f1 dot append EF
- what if we append ea3 they share the
same index and they have mostly the same
columns but they do have different
columns well that's not exactly the best
thing and that's very similar to what
happened with concatenate as well so
they concatenate and append are useful
okay but you just you can't do
everything with concatenation and
appending now the one thing that you can
do like for example is like we could add
a series so like we could get rid of
this and we could say s4 series equals P
series and then in here you add some
data for that series like maybe an 80 a
2 and at 50 okay
so that makes a pandas series and then
what you could say is DF 4 equals DF 1
dot append s and we might have to say
ignore index I think it'll still give us
an index so let's say ignore index
equals true and then print DF 4
huh that's it quite look at how we
wanted okay let's give a name to the
series so s equals PD that series this
is your series and then what we're going
to say is index equals and then this
will be a list three things and that'll
be HPI interest rate in gos GDP so HP I
copy paste copy whoops
copy paste and copy paste I try that one
more time there we go so what happened
was this right here is DF one and then
this stuff is the series information 82
and 50 right and then we appended that
to the end again that's not super
efficient but if you want to do it you
can do it that's how so anyways that is
concatenating and appending and what
we're going to be doing the next
tutorial is talking about joining and
merging data frames now this is more
likely to suit our purposes but that's
not to say that concatenating and
appending isn't useful they just have
different reasons why you might actually
do it we're more interested in adding
columns and then also sharing possibly
an index and stuff like that so that's
all going to be covering the next
tutorial if you do have any questions
comments concerns suggestions feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time